yeah George, George. Referred
to an English as Gog and Magog.
and there are many many things
that are said about Gog and
Magwag.
However, a large majority of
these things written in history
books, especially marks extens,
extensive, expansive books on
history and so forth. Well,
mention description
descriptions of these two
tribes that are otherworldly.
that they have drills for
tongues, that they have teeth
that are such and such
size and shape that their ears
have this kind of ears similar
to elephants and that some of
them are very very small and
short while others are very
very tall and big. All of these
descriptions are not authentic.
rather
The only sure thing that we
know about and with regards to
their description that they are
human beings Prophet mentioned
that on the day of
resurrection, it will be said
to Adam to separate
Those from his offspring who
are the people of hell He asked
how many are they? And he is
told 999 from every 1000.
The prophet then
and comment commented on this
saying that of you, there are
for everyone 999. This
narration articulates that they
are human beings and we have no
reason to believe that they are
otherwise.
mentioned in Surat asked to
build a dam to keep them at bay
you connect to giant mountains
at the opening or where these
two mountains part.
Would come out and they would
pillage and raid and and do all
types of terrible things. And
so
built this dam connected it,
and kept their evil at bay by
doing so for a time. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions in
that
this dam will be reduced to
rubble one day.
and upon such event will
descend on the people of the
earth as Allah here describes.
He says, When the dam of Gog
and Magog has been opened and
they from every elevation
descent. They are murderous
people. that will pillage, and
destroy everything in their
wake. Now,
beyond
these descriptions that
I have mentioned We don't
really know much about yet
Georgian Georgia. We know that
they're human beings. We know
of the events roughly that took
place with
when yeah George and George and
and we know that near the end
of time, near the hour, near
the day of judgement, they will
descend upon the people of
Earth and leave destruction in
their wake. However, more than
that, beyond that, what is
beyond that is unclear to us.
There are two opinions that are
considerable with regards to a
Georgian. One opinion is that
yet George and Matt George are
still kept at bay behind this
wall. Where this is? We don't
know. How this is? We don't
know. Some people have tried to
rationalize this by saying,
yeah, George and Matt, George
are some kind of alien species
that are not on Earth actually.
Others try to rationalize this
by saying that there is a
difference between
a said as mentioned in Surat
They tried to say that yet
Georgia are actually
underground and they're being
kept at bay by a wall that is
more of a cap than it is a
wall.
However, it's very possible
that they are kept at bay
somewhere on this vast earth
that we are unaware of. Are we
aware of everything? No. An
absence of knowledge is not
knowledge of absence. very
arrogant of us to assume that
we know everything and have
seen everything on this earth.
very possible
improbable yet possible The
other opinion and that is the
opinion of the majority of the
scholars. Another opinion, is
an opinion which states that
the dam or the wall of is not
actually keeping them at bay
anymore. It did. At one point.
However, as technology advanced
and as they reproduced and so
on and so forth. Yeah, Georgia
spread throughout the Earth as
human beings do. And what we
can gather from the verses in
the Quran. They had George and
Matt George are very far north.
Where north? This is what has
as concluded in Surat
and that this wall was built
there and that they remained
there kept at bay during the
time of the in ancient times
and later, they spread
throughout the Earth and
migrated and this wall
remained. and that these
Northern Asian countries, these
are actually the descendants of
George. and that this wall is
left as an indicator of the of
the hour. So, when Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
the gate or the wall of or the
dam of will be reduced to
rubble. This is a sign of the
day of resurrection and the
violence of George being
unleashed upon people rather
than a barrier keeping George
at bay. This is the opinion of
a Sheikh Abdul Rahman of
Insanity, Rahima Allah, one of
the great scholars of Tafsir of
contemporary times and others
of the from Al Azhar. and this
opinion is possible and
plausible. and as far as Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentioning
from every elevated from every
elevation they will descend
This in that context would be a
reference to modern technology
and how that would be used as a
tool of genocide against
mankind will continue inshallah
tomorrow.
[Arabic recitation]